but anyway let's crack into this one
this is the most excited i've been to
have a guest on today
because today's guest not only was one
of my favorite players growing up
he also became one of my favorite
players to play with and is without a
doubt
one of the greatest lads in world rugby
it is
the great conrad smith welcome snakey
oh what a welcome what a welcome it is a
pleasure pleasure to be here i've been
fortunate to listen to a few episodes so
now
i'm a part of it even better oh
i'm stoked i was going through your
journey again a little bit last night
and
what a journey you've had what a career
yeah a little bit different than most
but um
yes i've enjoyed it still going as well
it's not it's not over right
still not over yet obviously on the
field it's over but
uh i was thinking maybe a comeback was
coming
right well the way i've seen ma running
around in france
he's blue and beaten mine and beaten in
my club twice in the last
few months so yeah
oh the neckie the neckie could probably
do with her um
i've i've received that i've only been
back a few months but i had a lot of uh
i take it as a compliment that i'm
obviously still in all right shape that
day
some people just genuinely think i'm
still playing a lot of old people
oh yeah you're still playing friday i'm
retired i retired three years ago
are in good shape though oh a bit of
cycling i took him to uh
i was living right in a popular cycling
spot in france so when i
i retired i did a bit of running and
then jumped on the bike and um yeah it's
been uh
it's been a good good little hobby nice
so what is what are you up to at the
moment i've got lots of questions about
this what is the
what is the great snake up to right so
well i'm obviously back in new zealand
when i finished playing
um i had the two and a half seasons with
the club i joined in france and then
joined their
staff and um did a few different roles i
did i tried a bit of coaching
um my first season and then i had
up until a few months ago i was the
director of formation so i ran the
academy there
and that role i really enjoyed i'd sort
of um i think
found something that you know i was
pretty motivated about helping the
younger players at the club where we
were in france
and yeah and i'd still be there in doing
that
um if it wasn't for the intervention of
covert but um
when that's all came along you know we
took off here um
we had this year we sort of battled it
out like everyone
hoping that it would uh pass by but the
longer it went
um yeah family and i asked the club to
head back to new zealand
and fortunately i was able to pick up
work
with the international rugby players so
that's work i'd been doing
uh very part-time after i stopped
playing so they're based out of dublin
and yeah and i've just picked up more
work with them so i've come back to new
zealand and
able to work three to four they've
offered me even full-time work
since they just work over uh over zoom
like most businesses do now and
yeah it's that's keeping me busy back
back here in new plymouth and
working from home and um yeah
have you found have you found the
transition from playing to
the other side obviously you're you're
the sort of man who would
um who was never going to have an issue
with
finding work but have you found the
actual life
it's tough i i think and i suppose being
involved in player associations you you
do a lot of work and you talk to a lot
of retired players and so you're very
aware of
all the challenges around it and
everyone you talk to
like no one does it easy or even even
the ones
you know you sort of refer to me or i've
talked to people that i think oh you
know you just went straight into another
career
you know how did you do it but though
every
every retired player will say it takes
it's two or three years where
you just you know ideally
it's not like you're really struggling
or anything but
it's just not the same you know you're
never gonna find a career or a passion
that
suits you as much as rugby or or gets
you out of bed as
quickly as um a rugby career does so you
know i
i suppose i knew that going in and and
so i suppose i just lowered expectations
around um in terms of a career i wasn't
you know i didn't want to be a coaching
the top 14 team straight away i actually
you know looked forward to spending more
time with the family
and started very much part time and and
that that has suited me and now it's
been almost three years and
the work i'm doing now all the work i
was doing with the club i enjoyed it and
now you know it's a couple of months
into
sort of close to full time with the
players association and i really enjoy
this stuff as well so
yeah it's it's getting better so what do
you actually do with the players
association
so we're so internationally so we do
the issues obviously we work with world
rugby on a day-to-day basis so we're
um doing a lot of you know so for them
they'll
organize world cups they do sevens
women's rugby
um all those sorts of things at the
moment the global calendar is big on
their
agenda and so whether the player um
represented us so they'll come to us or
usually the case we're going to them
challenging them on whether it's rules
of the game
or potential calendars or international
windows
or tournaments with world cup or sevens
there's a lot of work going on with the
sevens
obviously around the olympics and so
we're our
job is to talk with players around the
world
and make sure we you know uh a voice
representing them and to
just to make sure that all these things
that world rugby are
organizing have you know the players uh
views at their um
at the forefront and yeah it's a cool
job it's got a lot of challenges but
um it feels like we're making a bit of
headway world rugby seem to be talking
to us and
giving us a lot more um time for for our
views which is which is always good
you'd have some good views no doubt
rugby's in good hands
i don't know if i'd say that no it's
it's look man
you spend some time here one thing you
realize how lucky
you we are in new zealand um and so
that's really my background
right so i the whole time i was playing
in new zealand i was with the new
zealand players association
and you know it's such a good
relationship that the players
association and new zealand have with
the internet you
and you realize how
[Music]
you know useful that is and how much
that is really a reason that you you see
the performance of teams
right through new zealand whether it's
the all blacks or age group or the
women's game
um i think a big part of that is the
involvement of players and
all the decision making and and that
doesn't mean it's a
friendly relationship but at times um
and you're seeing this even at the
moment there's
there's uh differing views between
players and
administrators but i think that's good
as long as
there's a possibility there for that
argument or if it is an argument or a
discussion to take place
because that just doesn't happen in
other countries and i think um you know
they miss out on it
yeah fair enough and another thing is
you you've gone right off the radar
obviously you've never had social media
and things like that
is there any reason behind your lack of
social media or
being being able to be reached by the
public and your fans
um no honestly i think you know
obviously i played through a time when
when i started it didn't exist
and then yeah i suppose when it all
came about i was already someone that
wasn't um
hugely comfortable with um
media presence like you know i was happy
to speak to media and
and i saw it as part of the job but it
wasn't why i played the game
you know i loved rugby and i was happy
to
um do my butt in terms of media
appearances and even sponsorship
appearances but it wasn't something i
looked for you know i didn't go out and
seek extra endorsements or anything like
that
you know even though the opportunities
did present themselves i was always
so for me social media was a bit like
that and i
and i was a bit surprised and i think i
still am
the amount of players that do take to it
like i have absolutely no issue
with the guys that do um and you know
that's
but i i don't think it's for everyone
and i see the the harm
you know if you can call it that or the
damage or the pressure that it puts on a
lot of guys and i just
i think a lot the majority of them like
they've made the decision
because at the moment you just think
it's that you have to that everyone does
it so you sort of
but that's it suits your personality or
it doesn't and i
think there's a lot a lot of people and
this probably extends beyond rugby
um they don't need to be on social media
like
you don't have to be on social media you
can't exist life does
go on without it like i'm i'm fine
without it like
the odd thing i miss out on and i was
like ah did that really happen yeah
you know people will say to me where
have you been you didn't know about that
i mean that would happen once a month i
think and normally what i have missed
out on isn't that really
that important
[Laughter]
but uh yeah so that was always my view
and sort of nothing's really changed
that
i mean i realize um i said before
there's a lot of
potential opportunities i've missed out
on by not being on social media but
like i say if that's what i need to do
to my viewers then
like it's if it's uh if it's a sponsors
opportunity or some other
work that i need to have social media
then
that's probably means it's not for me so
uh yeah
that's that's really been my view oh so
there'll be no
dancing videos of you on tick tock
coming out anytime soon
well obviously my kids are still young
so we're going to get to the stage where
you know my kids are like i say they
might well join it and i won't stop them
joining it but
for me like a parent sometimes you have
to join these things just to know what's
going on i don't want to be oblivious so
you never know one day hopefully it
won't be for another 10 years but
i might pop up somewhere well that's
interesting
have you got an age where you think it's
appropriate for your kids to
have social media wow this is getting
good
okay no i don't i don't and
i think like most parents you you sort
of talk about this while they're young
and you don't have
you just sort of prefer not to talk
about it because you know it's gonna
come and you don't know what you're
gonna do
but um yeah i i don't i don't think you
can of any [ __ ] age in mind but it's the
same with phones right like i don't know
at some stage it's gonna we're gonna see
the the usefulness of my son having a
phone so when he finishes school
or if he's gonna friends you know is
obviously a great
benefit to these things but uh yeah the
dangers or the risks that come with it
yeah
i just i just push that to one side at
the moment
fair enough me too anyway part of the
podcast that i love doing is going back
right to the start hearing how
um every all the guests grew up and so
what was it like for
what was it like for baby snake ah
that was good i was you know had a great
family who i'm still
very close with so i was born in harwar
but i didn't last long there my father
was a policeman so he then
he moved us or he was moved up to new
plymouth and the family
went there and that's where we've sort
of our parents are still there and we've
um we grew up there went to some good
schools that i
you know most of my friends are still
the friends of friendships i formed
during
school and and that was that was me a
couple older brothers
i played a lot of sport with sport was
obviously
uh yeah it was a big part of my life all
the way through
my dad was pretty handy he played
the taranaki and i had an uncle who was
an all black and a great uncle isn't all
black so rugby
was um you know it was a big part but
in saying that it wasn't uh we weren't
pressured in any way like we were pretty
um
have we started off just our family was
pretty relaxed the schools i went to
they weren't big rugby schools
and yeah and then i sort of left to
study
went down to wellington and um and
that's
that's sort of on a rugby front where
things took over but early life was just
cool it's just a
like i say a great great close family
and
a mum who uh spent a lot of time for the
kids and
only sort of worked later in life when
we were still all sort of older and um
but yeah so that that uh that's always
had a big impact on me i think
your family and why you brought up by
all accounts you were a pretty good fast
bowler too
yeah i played a lot more qriket than
rugby at school
um probably on account of my size i
wasn't very uh quite big enough i had to
play half back at school right up to 13
but
yeah number nine um
box kicking was not my strength
or right to left passing i could imagine
it wasn't i was one of those half backs
that just always would turn around
or run or or run from the left hand rack
i was just running to them
but uh cricket was um yeah
representative wise was where i played a
lot and actually broke down as
cricketers do with fast bowlers so i
still got a stress fracture in my back
that
if i have a backyard session that goes a
little bit too long and i go and i get a
little bit too competitive
i'd still wake up in the morning and
worse than any rugby injury after
16 years of whatever it was professional
rugby
few years as a young fast bowler
left me with a worse injury but no that
was uh
that sort of put play to the cricket and
i
i always loved rugby a little bit more
you know i think i'm just
personally suited rugby so crooked even
though it was
advancing far i don't think i would have
lasted long just
yeah the a pretty special cricketers
they uh
it's an individual team sport whereas i
always loved the
the camaraderie and rugby a little bit
more yeah
so then talk to me about your study and
then how did you make um the wellington
lions because obviously you were you
were still pretty young but you had a
pretty unorthodox
way to getting in there didn't you yeah
i just uh also
went to wellington to study um
still wasn't playing rugby i applied for
a uh
the academy then which had only just
started but i missed out
um i didn't play any representative
rugby at
uh under 19 level so i was just a
full-time student
and then it was my second year year down
down at university in wellington that i
um
i i made the premiere so i was playing
for old boys university and i made the
premiere side
and it was really gross like i was
saying before i'd been so small up until
then but i'd started
at the end of high school i shot up and
i my box kicking got even worse because
so i was so tall and my passing
even right to left was so bad because i
i was having to reach down you know
that's why you don't see
really tall halfbacks and it was so
i was admittedly i i didn't i i wanted
to be out in the
the midfield and um so i started playing
at
12 or so yeah my first year as a 13 was
only
um second year at university and i was
put out there and um
[Music]
yeah and as i say things it was a really
good
it was a really good club and i think
you know what i learned
i think throughout my career is if i was
on a good team i
was someone that looked good you know
whereas other players they can be in a
rubbish team but if they're a good
player they'll
stand out but if if i'm not in a good
team
no one's going to notice the center
that's running around you know
but uh but we our club was
um amazing in that and was super rugby
that
time um a lot of them would come back
and play half the club season we'd have
we're the back line of
spice um ton of villi for a while
uh paul steinmetz uh shannon parkou
oh hi there a couple other yeah and that
all come back and so there i was
with just slot in and um yeah
had a great couple of years and then so
suddenly i was um
i hadn't even trialled for the
wellington colts that year but
because i'd had a reasonable season in
the club so we had made the
i think the finals that year of the club
competition um and so i was sort of
asked to
come join the wellington cults and
sort of made so i played the back end of
that season with the colts and then
sort of from from there i was still
studying um
and but managed to get to my last year
of uh at university of my degree it was
my fourth year and
got got a got a phone call then to come
in and join the the wellington lions
um because their midfielders tanumanga
and matanon had gone off to the world
cup so
all about timing i um they were a bit
short there was a couple injuries and
yeah i got called into the called into
the lines had a couple of games we made
the final so again you start to look
good you get noticed you know the team
was playing well and
um yeah you know i was that into that
year i was in the hurricane so it
from from uh not even playing well into
the under-19s i was
then in the hurricanes and then played
my first all black game
at the end of 2003 so
from 2001 to 2003 was uh
yeah it all happened pretty fast
that's crazy and did you break your leg
somewhere in between there as well
no it was just after that i had um
thanks for
bringing that up just as i was feeling
good about it no
that was uh what was that that was 2006.
so i'd actually
um i played my sorry my test taboo was
04
and then i'd had oh five the lions came
i was still
you know i was picked within the all
blacks but and i was told
you know because tana had hinted to the
coaches that he wasn't going to be
playing for much longer
and they were looking for you know they
i was the i was selected to be groomed
and to take
you know over from him so i didn't play
a lot of tests and
05 and then um but yeah and then
he retired in 2005 so 06 was meant to be
my big year and i broke my leg and
and the second was the first game of
super rugby that year
back in new plymouth so some say it as
some sort of uh
some sort of curse because i'd left
talanaki as a young
this is my first my first game back at
rugby park since
going and playing for wellington uh yeah
snapped my leg pretty well
and that sort of took me out for the
next six months
and how was that uh how was that to deal
with
yeah it was tough well it was good in
that well i think you know
the fact that it happened when i was
early in my career and so you're still
very motivated i'd only just had a taste
of your blacks i was
you know there was never a doubt in my
mind i was going to get myself back and
um you know it just still had heaps to
prove i'd still only played a handful of
games even for the hurricane
so yeah it was and you heal quicker
right when you're young and so
it all went pretty well i was i was sort
of ahead of
sort of the schedule in terms of my um
when i was coming back i was sort of
healed pretty quickly the surgeons like
it was a bad break but
very clean um in terms of it was just
right across the bone so they were
able to pin the tibia and it healed
um really well and that that obviously
helped in the the recovery but yeah
certainly it was
i think most players will tell you the
toughest
time of your career is those those
injuries particularly those big ones
just because you
you're all alone like any you go through
rough patches with a team
whether you're losing games or whatnot
you're still experiencing that as a team
and you sort of you feed off that and
you can come together and you get
through it and you ever still can have a
bit of a laugh but
man the loneliness of an injury and i'd
been lucky up until
then you know like and that's when you
don't want the injuries when you're
trying to you know make teams like i was
fortunate by the time i broke my leg
even you know at least i played for the
all blacks and things so i wasn't it
wasn't about
losing um my position in the team it was
uh
but yeah it's just a very lonely battle
and you're just uh
there's a lot of moments where you like
i still remember when i first started
running
and then you just think man how am i
even gonna sprint you know i can barely
run
and then even my first i started back
playing club rugby back for obu
and god i reckon i would have been one
of the worst players on the park
and here you are you've got these these
ideas that you're going to get back to
being an all black and you're like man
this
this club team shouldn't even pick me
for next week
that's how bad i was
[Music]
but yeah you just you just have good
people around you that
support you and that's what i was lucky
enough to have and
yeah so then you look back on it and
think it was just a hiccup but at the
time it's yeah it's tough
you talked about your all black debut
against italy
what was that like how were the nerves i
know i remember
try it was an unbelievable try but it
took me through the whole experience
yeah it was it was amazing like you know
you know
it happened so quick the fact you know
in the same year i was
just joined the hurricanes and then by
the end of it i was playing for the all
blacks
which was probably a good thing and i'd
again we'd made the
the epc as it was in nbc final
um and so we we'd lost to canterbury a
very good canterbury side but then yeah
the team was selected i think the
two days later then we were assembled
then we're flying to italy and then bang
i was playing with the first game of the
tour
and it was probably a good thing because
it happened so fast and i didn't even
really
you know it didn't sink in that it was
that all this stuff was happening and um
so yeah you just saw that and i was you
know i had tana there playing alongside
me and
who had been fortunate enough to play
with a little bit by then so
those sort of things like still don't
get me wrong
barely slept the whole week all that but
but uh yeah it was just i was a great
you know i looked back
it was just an awesome experience it
goes so fast which most
um guys will say about their first game
for the all blacks um
but yeah and in a funny way it meant a
lot more because i had
i had my two older brothers who i said
was i was very close with they were
living in london at the time and because
my selection
and that happened in such a short window
they hadn't booked tickets or flights
um up until the team was named and by
that stage like it was sold out
there were no flights to get from london
because all these kiwis you know want to
get to the game
so as i'm going to but on obviously
trying like hal and
my brother my brother you know he has
lots of
issues with administrative problems he
realizes his passport was it had expired
as well
at this time so that that all just added
to it so as i'm going to the game i
don't even know if my brothers are going
to be there like that's how sort of
late it was and then it turns out they
i walk off the field and there they are
they'd come down and that was pretty
awesome um you know i hadn't seen the
old brother i hadn't seen for
about three years and because we didn't
have a zoom it wasn't zoom or skype back
then there was a
few few phone calls but uh no that was
that was real cool and so that made it
even more special because i got to
have the afternoon my parents you know
they didn't have time to organize
everything to get over
um they were the same they didn't want
to book flights to rome even though they
thought i might get selected
but um they didn't want to jinx it so
they couldn't be there but no
my two bros were there and yeah it was
it was an awesome day
let's go and you obviously went well
enough to keep your spot for a very long
time
all the way up until the 2007 world cup
do you want to talk to me about that
experience
the the ocean the world cup it was yeah
i say this that that is the best all
black team
i've ever been in in terms of a squad
like really
and that's crazy that everyone you know
looks back as they should you know we
got knocked out in the quarterfinals so
it was a failure but man and people
forget like those the couple years
before that when
we were changing our team every week and
winning by 30 40. it was incredible
group of players
i remember the the team was selected
each week there would be
well over two 300 cats sitting on the
bench or not even on the bench you know
i remember that game we had
anton oliver reuben thorne doug howlett
aaron major
um these guys couldn't even make the 23
like 22
and it was a yeah amazing group of
players
amazing coaching staff who went on to do
great things and
but you know we got we had a bad day and
and that's the beauty of the knockout
tournaments but
yeah it was uh and the world cup itself
like my
real first real taste of france it was
an amazing amazing tournament
and i can look back on it now and say
that because at the time you know for
the next
four or five years you because of the
result yeah
it sort of shadows everything right but
now i distilled some of my greatest
memories like off-field just the welcome
and the
the everything that had during that
world cup it was it was pretty special
um
time what'd you learn from that um world
cup you think
oh yeah a lot and and i think that's
you know why i say like that coaching
group like the decision to keep them as
hard as that would have been
um because of the result was was
you know set us up and most guys that
were involved through that
would say the same thing uh we we took a
lot of lessons just
around you know not taking it for
granted and the fact that we were
traveling so well in that world cup
but we weren't focused really just on
winning games and and that's
that you know failure shaped our
approach for the next
two world cups easily you know the whole
idea
of what had happened and the build-up to
world cups
are relevant and you just had to win
three knockout games like that's a world
cup that's all it is
and yeah you know the last world cup
where we didn't make it just reaffirmed
that you know
um these tournaments they are just
tournaments
entirely different and up until then i
think
as an all black group we had had this
amazing success as a
you know every season um and throughout
our history you know
of winning multiple games but when you
get to a tournament
it's totally different and you got to
expect teams to play differently
referees get influenced by pressure we
influenced by pressure and it's
totally different than any other test
and so you can't just rely on the
experience you've had
and even if you're trucking well and and
leading up to a world cup this is
you know this is something entirely new
and that's what tripped us
up at cardiff and it tripped us the all
blacks up at the last five world cups so
i just think that was the one thing and
we were we took him
from from there on in um based on that
experience
so then going to the 2011 world cup at
home
masses massive amounts of pressure how
did you how did you guys handle that one
uh well pretty well up until the final
you'd say
it was a great you know campaign and and
we like i said we've done
so much work around um just the mental
side of the game and dealing with that
pressure
um and and i and i think you know we we
still enjoyed it like because it could
have easily been a world cup
because like you say the pressure was um
immense but we we didn't try to hide
from it like we based ourselves in the
middle of auckland city we let guys go
out enjoy it we
involved ourselves as much as we could
and all the stuff that was happening and
and it was great i just think we it was
still
you know a real it was a tough
tournament
um wearing all that pressure but i i
think we were still performing
really really well and then that we we
got to a final and
i've still haven't watched it properly
but um
i know by that stage we were just all
about
dealing with things we couldn't expect
you know like i was saying before
whether it was going to be
referee decisions or opposition playing
out of their skin and
and that's what happened in the final
what i look back on as france
being france playing even a style of
play that they'd never shown before and
with the
intensity that they hadn't shown losing
to tonga and
losing to you know other other team and
and losing to us by 30 points in the
first game of the tournament like it was
just a
really difficult game to get ourselves
up for and never mind you know the
injuries that we were
facing and the fact that we were looking
back
really on our last legs we'd been so
you know that semi-final against
australia was one of the two or three
best
games i'd played in um in my whole
career so
but i think that was because we were we
were expecting to play australia in the
final
and and that building up to that world
cup they were a team that had deepened
us obviously a couple of times and
um we we spent a lot of emotional energy
in that game i think and
but hey we we got through a final where
and we had said there'll be games and it
happens every world cup
the teams that win you'll there'll be
games that you don't play your best but
you still got to find a way to win
and um yeah that happened in that final
did you feel the pressure while you're
out on the field or is it more building
up to it because like
my experience i never played at the all
black level but i always felt the real
pressure leading up to the game but as
soon as on the field i was sweet was it
is the is the world cup the same or is
it you're still feeling it while you're
out there
no it it's the same right you ideally
yeah that that's
um that's something you feel monday to
friday
and then and then yeah by the time the
game i mean
sure if it's if it's too big and it can
creep into
like your subconscious and then it can
sort of cloud your judgment
um and cloud your performance
on the field and so that's when the
pressure can have an effect but
yeah like normally by the game time
certainly in terms of the
the crowd and things like that most guys
are able to
well you have to you know you don't
really get to that level if you can't
shut that out and
um perform but who knows like there's
still an impact that it does have
subconsciously and and and that's what
you know i suppose we've talked about in
the past that
that pressure of like not even though it
wasn't a home world cup but i know seven
and at that pressure of
having not won a world cup for so long
because that was definitely a factor um
and it was again obviously in 2011 but
you know just the
the fact of talking about it i i think's
always the best i as soon as you
just be straight up and say look this is
an issue
how are we going to deal with it and
then you know then you just turn it on
its head and suddenly you try to use it
as
something to motivate you and that's by
the time game time you trying to use
that pressure to motivate you and that's
uh generally the best way to deal with
it
like that and then obviously the uh
following world cup 2015 you'd won the
previous world cup
so was the pressure a lot less did you
feel like there's a little bit of weight
off your shoulders
yeah a little bit and i suppose like
because that's what a lot of people i
suppose
thought and feel but i think even after
2011 we were quite
quick to keep putting pressure on
ourselves to perform because i think we
felt like all blacks obviously hadn't
won world cups
up until the end but the reason we were
still considered the best team in the
world was
like every test match for an all black
even if it's not a world cup final we
want to win
and and i know for me
you know it was slightly annoying that
so many
people and they still do put place such
reliance on the world cup as defining
you as a good team whereas
you know for 20 years right all blacks
didn't win a world cup but we were still
you know you asked most people that we
were considered the team to beat in the
world
so we wanted that just because we won a
world cup now is the time to prove we
really are by just continuing that
that's why that for me that period was
really important and we only performed
so well because we put a lot of pressure
on ourselves and
15 it was the same we we just we had a
group of guys obviously that were all
leaving and we just really wanted to win
so
i just think the pressure on ourselves
like you say there was
no doubt it was the external pressure
wasn't the same but internally
i think we wanted to win that one almost
even you know even more just to
make a statement you know before
obviously a few of us left but
also just to cap off that sort of four
years that we've had since the last one
um where we had it had a good amount of
success and
been a pretty you know strong group yeah
well
my memory of that 0-15 team was that it
was the most stacked
all black team and probably history but
you got you saying that 07 team would
beat them
aren't you well i i just and again
that's but that's me like as a player
because i know seven
everyone was you know i was looking up
to all these guys whereas i'm one of the
old guys now
you're the guy so yeah
it was just for me you know seven like
there was and
but i still would say that taken as a
squad like a 30-man squad
i don't know you could do the stats but
i'm sure there'd be more cats in that
team
in 07 and there'd be more all black wins
and there'll be
probably more super titles i don't know
but it was just
it just felt like an incredible team
because yeah
leading into that a lot of guys had come
back it was just a different
whereas there was a lot of youth but oh
no doubt that i mean the 15 team
that you know we went through that world
cup it was
it was incredible the the talent on that
side and um
yeah other people will will say look we
want to world cup
the team in 07 got knocked out in the
quarters so
there's never going to be a debate as to
who's of his team but uh
i i i just think it's interesting when
you look at the actual squad
i don't think there's much between them
yeah but it was obviously a very
fairytale way to finish your
international rugby career going out
with another world cup
apart from one little moment which still
breaks me and i want to know the reason
behind it the early
final sub what the heck happened injured
surely well
no you have to ask steve hanson and uh
and ian foster no they look up
up until then you know they'd talk to us
about being a
three you know with sunny playing so
well um
the three of us you know he had changed
us
in and out all the games and he said
look it's just going to be
he's it'll be my hunch is the way the
game progresses if he if he felt like a
team was ready to break he liked the
idea of sonny coming on
um if it was tight as in the the week
before
and felt you know there was qualities
that i'd bring to a game then ma would
get exited and sunny would be brought on
and
and then there was still the option to
bring sonny on to start so
um you know they they were open and
honest with us
i mean it hurt me too mate don't get me
wrong it's probably 40 minutes
i'm normally a slow starter to a test
match i i think it's the first
40 minutes i've ever played and um
yeah i won't repeat what i told stephen
when he told me i was coming off at half
time it was uh
but look man he you can't question him
and now and even after like i'll choke
with uh
steve about it now because uh yeah
that's the way he coaches you know and
he says in himself he's a punter he
he loves his horses and and that was the
way he sort of coached sometimes and he
just felt
that sonny was going to do something and
look they did they sort of broke the
game open the two of them so
yeah it was uh it was a little bit
strange because i've never been subbed
off
ever after 40 minutes and here it was in
the world cup final but
you soon learned to bury those personal
things and
soak up you know could have been a lot
worse i mean there was
mates afterwards you know sat down next
to woody tony woodcock you know and he'd
pulled his hammy and missed
that part of that tournament and you
know he's played a lot more tests than
me and uh
so you know that's just funny and you
just have to
find get get over those things so what
were you like on the bench
what during that last half yeah i was
still
man i was into it to when i sat next to
gilbert and okay who was on the mic and
um you know i kept i kept involved as
much as i could be and and
you know i was worried especially the
way
the game sort of did pan out and and
part of me was thinking
you know especially when ben got sinbin
if you remember he ben smith got
sunburned and
i think that's when even steve would say
you'd want me back on the field because
i think we lacked a little bit and
worked great and obviously we were down
a man
um so that was if we'd lost from there
may i wouldn't be talking to you i think
i'd still be hiding out somewhere in
there
but again that was just for the team so
i was uh but look the guys got home and
so you know we didn't need to go down
that path
and how were the celebrations yeah they
they were good they were probably
like i was saying um you know
like the world cups are they are tough
like that's the longest you're ever
together
uh in your career and as a camp and like
we see before the pressure and
even though we weren't in new zealand um
there was still a lot of pressure from
there's a lot of kiwis over there
following and supporting here we it was
awesome the support um
coming across from new zealand as well
uh so you're
you're pretty tired like you always
think it's going to be this
huge party but um you know look you
celebrate but
most yeah like i just remember more so
in 2011
um and again that might have been
depressive i remember having a couple of
days you do the parades and things like
that but then just
wanted to go home and sleep like i think
i was just at home for like four or five
days after
the new zealand world cup and the
english
obviously being in england it sort of
extended because we had a couple of days
in london and then come back and do the
parades in new zealand so
uh but at that stage i knew i was done
so i think i
allowed myself to enjoy a little bit
more
oh good times and one part of your
career that we
haven't even touched on you and probably
my favorite part of your career
you are a hurricane legend absolute
legend the greatest hurricane of all
time
how how is that career any standouts for
you
uh for sure i think even
like alongside the great things you know
i experienced with the all blacks i
think
um 2012 with the hurricanes is always
um i don't know probably my most
enjoyable
season and for those a lot of people
sort of forget and i think that's why i
enjoyed even more but you know we had
been
in 2011 lost a lot of
key players um so you know i was
elevated to captain we were a
side under a huge amount of pressure we
weren't expected to win a game
we've been absolutely slated in every
piece of media um you know for the
coming season and
hammett was under mark was under massive
amount of pressures
obviously with mar and andrew leaving
which he had a part to do with but then
on the back of that in the mirror and
pity and jose
and um there'd be three or four i'm i'm
forgetting that
that all left and so i i was nervous i i
spent that whole summer
just thinking how how are we going to
get through this and
and i mean i was there was no question
of me not
you know i was going to stay whatever
happened i loved the team i'd grown up
loving the team so
it was you know all my thoughts were is
how can we
get the best out of us and how can i
help all the young guys that had come in
to
to be proud of being a hurricane and um
you know and sort of
let the supporters who were there's a
lot of disappointing supporters
how to bring them back and um get behind
us and then
but by the end we were playing in front
of a packed house
we beat the chiefs who went on to win it
that year in our final game because we
still had a
chance to make the semis um and no one
would have given us
like that even that alone the fact that
we had a chance to make the semis go
into the last week
and then still beat the chiefs to keep
our chance alive like
uh that that's i mean that's why it's my
favorite memory and
um i've managed to play through it all
and see some
young tj pirinara and bodie barrett and
jimmy marshall come to the fore
and uh yeah it was it was it was a great
year it's still like i say
my favorite one of my favorite times and
one of the
my favorite memories i was watching
obviously but you scored the
absolute one of my favorite tries 80
something minutes against the blues talk
me through that one
yeah it was uh it was a you know again
the blues were
highly favored that year and we went up
eden park
there's something special about that
place i'm easily playing with this rugby
eden park
i'd like to say i'm still with that or
whatever it's called now wellington
stadium's
my favorite to go to but something about
eden park
brought something out of me and and you
know there we were and
with a sniff of winning that um right it
right at the end and
body makes a break and i run at them and
uh
it just i don't know it was something
about that year was
we had a bit of luck don't get me wrong
but uh we were beating all these
kiwi teams and uh that's what i just
love so much so it was uh it was a lot
of passion obviously
it came out in the way i used to
celebrate sometimes but
it was only passionate because there was
a lot of hurt that had gone on along
you know before that i run it in that's
the most humble
answer to your try oh you showed speed
fitness what under the post it was the
80th minute
i'm gonna win a sprint it's gonna be in
the 80th minute
but it wasn't the first i'd be looking
for a winger straight away
oh cracker and you talked about being uh
becoming captain how did you
how did you feel with that
responsibility
uh yeah i love like by the end
i loved it it motivated me i think
i i think you look at a lot of other all
blacks and look
we talk about this but when you're
playing a lot of tests super rugby
you'd never say it's a it's a chore but
it can challenge a lot of guys
i don't think that's anything too um
controversial me saying that but for me
playing for the hurricanes and then
having that captaincy in my last
four seasons i i loved it and i never
even
it was never one or the other you know
there was it was never
obviously the all blacks it was it was
an added motivation but
playing for the hurricanes uh it was it
was huge for me and
um being captain was was something i i
loved and kept that motivation
right to the end uh i i was a reluctant
leader
in terms of you know and i'm just like
that naturally
you know my first four years probably
with the team i hardly see the word
and you know and so it sort of took a
bit of prompting
before being made captain but um
you know and even with the all black
leadership group like i was
very almost reluctant to to take that
sort of responsibility but
some people are like that and you just
need a push and then after that i
you know i loved it and that uh it was
something
um yeah i looked back on and made it
particularly enjoyable
while i was kitten and able to uh to
help out all the younger guys
and a massive help you were and then one
moment that comes up
a lot throughout this podcast as a big
moment in a lot of hurricanes career
the 2010
final talk me through your experience of
that big final
yeah it was uh it was tough it was
probably the toughest loss
to deal with um i had i'll i will say
though
like you know looking back on it now it
was um
and i suppose i even within four or five
months i it was uh
and like we've talked about before like
finals footy
it's fine lines like fine margins and
i look back at that game and
it could have easily gone the other way
like i don't
regret the way you know there were some
things we could have done differently a
little bit with our approach um
but we played you know all i was worried
about going into that final is that we
might have gone into our shells if
anything we did the absolute
opposite and we because and to be fair
to us that sort of done so well for us
you know we
finish top of the ladder by just playing
we were running that kick-offs the
majority of the time
we were attacking teams um always
thinking attacking and it was what i
loved i
and it brought the best out in us and
that's how we were winning so
um i i think in hindsight we needed just
to
take it down on that a little bit
because the highlanders
they threw everything back you know and
it would just turn into this
rather entertaining almost unfinal like
game
um and look and then and then it just
comes down to a couple of key moments
and
even calls that go against you like
anything
like what happens in sport in the same
way i talk about the
2011 world cup you know against france
and that's a game we could have lost
like
we talk all the time now about oh you
know we're a great team and we prepared
so well
the fact the matter is like you know
they had a kick a penalty kick with
what was it 10 minutes to win that had
gone over history's totally different
you know and
as much as you like to say oh it's
because of our preparation
i don't think you can always say that
and
so we could have lost that game but we
could have easily won that final i
honestly think that if we played it
ten times i still think we would
probably win it six or seven times
um but you know that those those things
happen and
for me it hurt but it made
the team winning the final the following
year
completely gave me so much closure and
i've told a lot of the boys this but
i don't even know if they believe me
because they'd always apologize and say
oh
we should have won it the year before we
should but honestly
i watched that game in spain as
bizarrely as it was i was
obviously in france where i went up the
holiday watched the guys win that
and i don't know if i've ever felt so
good about a game
i wasn't even involved in but it was and
it lasted for like weeks i just had this
glow on me
like and i realized now like it was that
that weight of i think losing that final
because you know my motive like i don't
have i've sort of seen the site
personally
i don't the fact that i was involved
with the game is no big deal
and like if i was injured and i miss a
game as long as the team wins and so for
me
like my last four years particulars
captain with the hurricanes i just
wanted us
to be respected you know and i just
wanted us to be seen as a great team
and the easiest way to do that is to win
the to win the thing
so when we lost you know i knew we'd
still had a great year but
like if it's still today and hurricanes
hadn't won a title
i i'd be still i'd probably be in tears
talking about that again
but the fact that we won a new one like
the following year like
mate i was just look that's what i
wanted like we got our title with and
even better
we had two years where we were the top
dogs and suddenly
you know the hurricanes were talking
about us as a people sorry we're talking
about the hurricanes as a
as a you know as an elite performer and
and that was my goal not about winning
titles necessarily but
and there wasn't anything about personal
about me being there or
it was just seeing the team um have that
respect again so i was
it was it was a proud moment for the old
dog sitting in
san sebastian
you see that one coming obviously um we
the the squad lost a lot of leaders you
ma and a few others um that i can't
quite remember but
um did you think the following year
there was gonna they were still going to
be able to do
that yeah i did and i remember even
during the season i remember talking to
boydy and plums about
um so the season you know before that we
were playing i
i remember at length talking about
because
i i suppose you you realize like there's
a huge value in
in the leaders you have but it's also
that that next tier and so that's why i
didn't see a problem because
you know there was yourself there was
bodhi there's tj guys in
crucial positions cozy shields like all
these guys that were coming in
and i even knew during that season they
were already
doing a lot of the leadership like there
was myself obviously ma thrushy
these guys that were all going but i i
just
and i you know we discussed a lot and i
even talked to
boydy during the season the following
season
and i and i said you know this is
exactly what i wanted
what i almost expected to see happen um
and even not just that year but for the
two or three following and
um yeah and i would have been gutted if
we
went backwards because again like that's
your whole
my whole motivation was to create a good
club not to have a one-off season you
know like we
won that year and then ended up last i
think i would have been more gutted than
what ended up happening us losing the
final but then winning it next year
because that's
yeah that's what you want to do as a
captain you know like you don't want it
just to be about you you want it to be
a great club around you so um and it's
the same with the all blacks like i know
talking with richie and down and that
like we all left in 15
16 the guys played even better and it
was
and that's that's awesome like you don't
want to see them drop off a club
everyone would say oh that's because you
guys left and so it might feel
that you know yeah that's not the way
most guys work you know most like you're
like
you're proud of the team you're proud of
the all blacks you just want to see them
um go even better and see these guys
step into the roles that you've left
that's so true such wise words and one
thing that happened
uh at the end of 2015 after we'd lost
the final
i remember everyone was pretty upset but
at 3
30 or something am in the morning you
challenged tj paranara to a
yo-yo on courtney place
[Laughter]
and he was giving me luck and so i said
here's your chance buddy
he i think he even named the time and
then where was he at three that he was
nowhere to be found
number one i won by default and remain
remain undefeated well i think he's
still telling people that he won that
one he must have been hammered
he was back in bed i tell you that much
well it cracked me up that there was a
whole build up of talking about this
yo yo just constant trash talk
i would have loved to see the habit
because it would have happened if he was
there
yeah i don't know if we would have set
any records but
geez that would have been entertaining
you wouldn't have lost many yo-yos
throughout your career though
no no it was something i uh prided
myself on i
i i think i've said you before anyone
that see me in the gym
knows that i need other places
on the within the uh training to to
excel because my form in the gym is
pretty much horrific
and so that was that i was i knew i was
going to be the worst
you know and all the other testing the
the bench and your
weighted chins all your squats so i was
like right i've got to win this to give
myself some respect here and
make sure and this started from when i
was you know first in the team
because at that time you're like if they
see my gym steps they're going to wonder
what i'm doing there
so at least if i won the fitness then
i'm like okay
he he'd give him another contract he can
stay he's not
he's not a complete waste of time but
yeah what was that yes
what was your best yo-yo i was just
doing a davey grave out there it was
uh 20 what would be geez i want to feed
it now
you were there we were you as you me and
bodhi right to the end
20 was that your best one you beat me by
one yeah
yeah i bet you buy one but then there's
the they got a young halfback that
blew it out of the water this year has
he what did he get
yeah he got 20 whatever we we were like
21
4 or 5. he's done like 23-1
he went like a whole level swinney maybe
yeah what he weighs about he weighs
about
72 kilos i feel bad i can't remember his
name but
yeah it's that's always the better
response i
oh he weighs nothing it has to be i
can't just take it
but yeah oh how good good times at the
hurricanes and then
obviously you went over to france so
took me through that move what what what
was the reasoning behind that move
um though i was i was
spent for the lack of another word it
was um
it was uh like we just started a family
which was a
huge factor um so the time away
just with you know super rugby as it was
then with the trips to south africa in
australia and then
being involved you know heavily with the
all blacks uh
you know and and all the time away it
was you know three
in a world cup years four months and it
was just
sapping my enjoyment and i never wanted
uh you know when you talk about
playing for the all blacks i never ever
wanted to feel
like i didn't want to be there or even a
part of me not you know
missing home because then you know if
that's going to affect your performance
and you want to be giving you all for
your country and it's uh
so yeah it was actually i suppose it
started in
2014 and then i just knew by
15 it was uh and it was i mean obviously
the world cup was
the timing was was good but it wasn't
really
even that like if there had been if that
was in the middle of world cup so i
still would have gone then and um
yeah and so then it was just a matter
when i knew i didn't want to play all
blacks it was
whether i stayed playing for the
hurricanes and not the all blacks
which i thought about for a while but it
was
again i just didn't know how that would
work and obviously i'd talk to tana
because he'd done that and
um he was pretty good and telling me
that it's it's
in its own way it's a bit of a battle um
and so i i
looked overseas which i hadn't done at
all in my career
and um i it was going to be a family
decision and i talked to
lee my wife and we liked the idea of the
language so it was
pretty much i told an agent we needed to
be in france or to leave
i wanted a kiwi coach or someone that i
could trust
and that they weren't going to tune me
out every week because i was obviously
34 by then and and it needed to be like
i didn't we didn't want to go to paris
or
you know a big city we were obviously
wellington were both from the plymouth
so
and i thought that would be an
impossible challenge and then within a
week the agent came back and
simon mannix kiwi who i'd met before
from wellington and
he coached a small french club who
weren't in the top 14 but were
confident of being promoted and it was
just too good and i didn't
you know so i didn't shop around i just
said look that's
i talked to simon and he uh and it just
made sense so that we could finish rugby
and
and then just go and it was really just
a lifestyle decision just go live in
france and
um play rugby while i could if the rugby
if i didn't enjoy
the rugby i would just retired but we
still wanted to live overseas and
um i would have picked grapes or done
whatever
how could that you've just basically
written your own contract and just got
it a week later
what a big time it's awesome
yeah well a lot it was just uh it was
just
yeah good it was funny just the way it
was it literally was just like that and
finally he flew to see me
and then um so i so i signed the
contract they were still on prodi dirt
so
i mean i don't know how that would have
gone down he was really confident that
they were going to play in the top 14
but
i was going to them regardless and um so
yeah that sort of mean
i wasn't interested in i didn't have
rugby aspirations in europe so i didn't
and i just mean that by like i didn't
want to go win the top 14 or go play in
the
european cups and yeah like my
i'd had whatever it was 10 11 years neil
black so that was
more than i ever thought i'd play so you
know
but i really like the idea of helping a
club in france and
more it's been you know you just have so
much time with your family over there
and
and i'd always wanted to speak a
language and
yeah so that was that was the motivation
in the end
how was your french yeah it's not bad i
um it took it was the toughest thing
i have ever done i'll easily say that i
spent
two three seasons as a player and never
got
i and looking back i was developing but
it's a personality thing speaking
languages as well and i like i sort of
said before i don't
confidently just start spitting off like
some people do
and they excel really quickly i was the
complete officer i didn't speak for
two or three years and then it was only
i started
obviously coaching and coaching you're
expected to speak in french and that was
the best thing for me because it just
i i wasn't great to start with but it
forced me to speak and i'd obviously
done a lot of work
i just i loved doing the lessons and
everything and
and sort of now on look i'm i'm not
fluent but uh
i'm rugby fluent i put it that way i can
speak rugby french and
hold a conversation but yeah i can't
uh speak french politics or uh go into
too many other subjects without gripling
looking for
google translate or
oh that's good and is it true that you
only were playing
home games that's a yeah that was
threatened
admittedly in really i'll clear this up
when i arrived i was obviously on the
back of the a long
super rugby world cup so i got over
there in december
and the way that that season turned out
that
the club all they wanted to do was
survive we
got out and the la the bottom two get
relegated and
i played maybe the first four or five
games the club did really well
and then we were in a position where we
couldn't make the playoffs
and we couldn't get relegated so from
that point on it is true that i only
played the home games
but the following season it was it was
normal but i was just tarnished with
that because that was like my first
three months and everyone saw this
and oh look they're all the frenchmen oh
you only play the home games how do i
get that contract
oh classic but they put a massive
emphasis on their home games over there
right is that something you try to
change or
that's just something that they they do
yeah interesting i
i did it and because i know i was uh my
it was only my second game we actually
went down and so a few
like myself colin slade um
who else did we have by that stage we
ended up with a few more but
early on there was a few us and we went
down and one in montpellier
and at that time i i've never seen
scenes like this in the changing room
because
it had like we had won the top 14 and
and played
like it was a great one i knew
montpellier was a good team but the fact
that we had won
at montpellier was just and it was only
like
sometime after the game that someone
said like we'd
done that in the 50s or something you
know like it just hadn't
this doesn't happen um and so and i
remember sort of
from then on sort of saying to the guys
you know like there's no reason
that can't happen again like you know
it's not a way home in a way
but it's funny how it changes you like
by the end
you you just understand the passion that
comes with a home game in terms of the
support like it's
that that's why like the support is
amazing at these home
venues these home fixtures like the
crowds and it's a day of entertainment
like they are there from
two hours before kickoff and the whole
community
like it's it's their event and it's
there's
business going on and they're out there
around the outside and it's a family
atmosphere and it's just all so if you
were to come and
as an away team when you are like
spoiling the party and it's um
and and and i think that sort of almost
influences the psyche of teams but uh
now i i try to change it but you know
what's changed at the most is covert
because this year um away team they're
obviously with no crowds
it's it's just uh and they've already
set records for the amount of away he
wins
in the in the top 14 there's still 10
rounds to go
and i actually think post covered like
surely
teams are going to realize like it's
actually just a crowd
you know like it's uh but they influence
referee's decisions there is
no doubt about that and and i'm not
blaming referees for that because these
crowds are
that hostile i was refereeing i i'd be
i'd be turning
decisions as well because they uh the
noise they can produce and the stadiums
are so close
i almost agree with them sometimes and i
see the calls blatantly wrong against me
but i'm like
yeah i i could understand i wouldn't
make that call either
how does new zealand replicate that oh
i don't know and it's not to say that
you know the new zealand
like new zealand rugby is amazing like
the the product i'm talking about like
what we play
and um and you're talking about
your population base right like it's
it's just not the same
these you know these are all in big
cities you know where they get the
crowds
and they don't have the same amount of
rugby and um
so like that's going to be hard to
replicate i i think there is a lot of
work that can be done just around
the the package of rugby rather than
just being uh
going to watch a game like i think you
can involve
the families the communities a little
bit more and but i know there's lots of
people looking at that and it's
uh and it's just always going to be a
cultural
challenge i think so i don't know i
can't give you a straightforward answer
i'd love to know it because i think
there's obviously there's just as much
passion in new zealand it's just
um it comes out in different ways well
you're in the right job to change it
looking forward to seeing looking
forward to seeing your work
in action anyway one thing i wanted to
talk about before we get to the
questions is your chat
your charity is it so they can is it a
charity that you're a part of
do you want to talk about that and how
you got into that i
um there i i met cass who
was the founder um just by chance in
wellington
and she had just started the charity so
this is yeah it's a charity that's
set up in australia new zealand but to
support the communities in kenya and
and um like
you know when you get to an all black in
a position
where you know you can influence people
over things like this
she she was keen but you get approached
a lot all right that's what i'm trying
to say about different charities
different things to the support
and but she was really passionate and it
was it appealed to me because it was
very small it related to her she had
personally
been over to the into the community and
seen um
what they needed and her motivation was
all about schooling and education
because if you just keep throwing money
at these communities then it's just a
it's too big a problem but if you can
actually
put it towards education and let them
actually find their own solutions
you know it makes sense right and so
that sort of appealed to me and i just
sort of said
like i'd love to actually if i was going
to support you i'd be involved you know
i didn't just want to be a
spokesman without seeing what they did
and and then she sort of like
called me out on it and said well go on
then here's uh this is where they are is
what they do and at that stage
uh my wife and i were planning a trip
and we were thinking about going through
africa so
that sort of started and then so i we
went there and we spent a week
in um kenya in a little hut that had no
power and water
and we it was part of a three month trip
this was after the 11 world cup actually
and it was eye-opening and the first two
days
i think if you'd offered us a chance to
leave we probably would have taken it
but by the end it was um and still is
like it was the best part of that whole
trip
and so we had a week there and we we saw
that these
so by this stage they just started the
school the
charities they set up a school and they
had volunteers they only had two
classrooms
and the plan was they would help the
help the school become self-sufficient
and if they did that they'd build
another classroom so it was the whole
idea of
them helping themselves not just um in
our western
charity giving them money and yeah and
now it's
like in that so what's that 10 years ago
it's now a full school
it's got another one it's got a
teacher's college because they realize
part of the challenge
you need good teachers as well and it's
just gone
further and further and we went back
again um two years after
we now have kids so it's actually really
hard because there's a lot of
immunisations and things to get there so
i've sort of felt bad
that i've i haven't been able to be
involved as much in the last few years
but uh but they're still doing great
things and yeah i try and help out where
i can
which is it's been a bit of a challenge
in france but now that i'm back on
um yeah getting involved again and and
seeing them uh
keep doing the good work they do that's
good stuff how was it seeing those kids
and stuff over there living those sort
of lifestyles yeah it was
just like it was yeah eye-opening and
and we didn't have kids at the time so
i think it's because we talk to our kids
all the time about it now right like we
when they ask for another toy or
something i love just saying do you know
you know
and we've got the photos that we say
look this is what these
these kids played with and or if they
complain about their meal you know we
want something different for breakfast
and i'm like i've got these photos i'm
like
you know these beans this was their
school lunch they had the same lunch
every day and they would and this was
something the charity provided so this
was
a meal they wouldn't otherwise have and
they were so happy these kids they would
come up
politely take their bowls which honestly
you'd offer this to a kiwi kid no one
they wouldn't eat it
but they would take it away it was the
highlight of their day most of them
hadn't had breakfast before they arrived
and they'd eat that and then
you know every day would be the same and
but you know
so i'm no teacher so but i we wanted to
help out of the class so
we had a rugby ball and most of them
didn't know rugby either
but yeah oh the enjoyment like kids are
kids
it's the coolest part they they're
living in tents or and they don't have
anything they don't get fed well but
they are
the happiest kids and it's uh
it's it's so awesome it's yeah pretty
inspiring you still
this was 10 years ago i still remember
it so well all they wanted me to i just
kicked
high balls up and they would just be
honestly we could do it for an
hour i was trying to change the game
yeah my box
was bad they didn't know i was a
runner's kicker
i was trying to change the game to
relays but i just want to see the shrug
we all go up and down all circle around
try and catch it but yeah then you just
do simple things and
and it it's just it's not like you know
we are living and the the conditions are
in for
the children it's just amazing they
don't know any different and
they're just so motivated as well so
yeah it's pretty easy when you see that
it's like man you just
to just to give them an education and
let them try and
um work out a way to help themselves
would be uh
such a such a cool goal so it was always
easy to
you know whenever cass would ring and
ask for me to
do something or to try and you know help
out to fundraise somehow it was always
so easy to say yes
life instead of perspective those
experiences just seeing
how people live yeah and we can't wait
to take our kids because i i just think
you know for yeah like it was amazing
for us but to take you know even my son
like i say it's one thing to show
photos but i just know be such a
experience to see what their schools are
like like even yeah it's a it's a great
school
but by new zealand standards it's
you know it wouldn't be a school uh
yeah and that's all that's what they
live with and uh like i say
and that's what they're happy with and
then it was actually improvement on what
they've had so
for the food run you know when you see
that can't help but
um it gives you more than you're giving
them in a strange way you know what i
mean like
you're giving me maybe actually when you
go over there you actually take away
just as much just by you know seeing
what they
how they live and and how they still
find happiness and
it's pretty amazing how can any water
lead listeners um
get behind that or donate to that um
yeah they're constantly
um obviously there's a few different
ways you've put me on the spot here but
they uh now
you you can you can sponsor the the
classrooms you can
they're actually at the moment i don't
know when this is going here jimmy but
um
they a lot of people would are trying to
uh
fundraise and you and you can sponsor
i'm actually trying to cycle
500 kilometers this month um to support
the uh
the woman in the in the communities who
are
put up to some um they have pretty nasty
living
standards without going too much into it
and so
there's a whole host of ambassadors that
uh have given themselves challenges and
are
trying to get sponsorship so you can
even sponsor me if you really
really want but uh here we go that's
probably the perfect
situation to get started we'll send me a
link and i'll post it because i know
you're not on social media so it's going
to be hard for you
i don't i don't i'll be laying the chain
so that would be good
only my family's donated to my cause so
uh i need a
i need to spread the word a bit wider
fair enough so well as always we've gone
to our instagram for some questions
and oh when you get one of the greatest
players of all time to come on
the questions come rolling in i will
just choose a few
as your time is very precious
uh
when did snakey realize he was one half
of one of the world's greatest centre
partnerships
good question um i i get asked about it
a bit
i think ma i would say the same that
like
we started both like competing for the
same spot so it wasn't like
uh we were a well-oiled partnership from
the get-go we were uh
you know we got on well but we
obviously different backgrounds and we
were like i say
computers and and i think actually that
part of it's um
just the fact that we're individually
motivated
sort of you know got us halfway to where
we ended up because we
both wanted to play uh it took us a long
time um
you know he he was in and out of the all
black side
it was sort of as a utility and then a
you know winger a center 12.
um i had you know injury issues and
uh leading up to really after 2007
because 2008 was the first time even
though we'd been
together for four or five years that we
um
played together in the midfield and but
i think from then on
and it was really you know the coaching
staff at the all blacks graham wayne and
steve that made us you know
realized that there was value in working
together like up until then
and all through you work on yourself and
you make yourself
the best you can be but you also you
know
if we were going to keep playing in the
midfield we need to understand each
other better and
from then on you know it was uh it was
work and we
you know it benefited us most uh both
massively and uh yeah it was it was
by the end of a very good friendship
that you know he's the one guy
still probably talked to more than
anyone else that i played with so
uh great guy and obviously we had good
good fun together on the footy field
no doubt were you faster than him this
was another question someone sent a
video to back
back it up you scoring a try i think it
was against france or something off a
grubber
do you remember that fiji at carrisburg
i'll remember it well
oh fiji there we go i think he just used
to score more tries in there he actually
gave me that one
but no i i would have to have i would
have to have the running race extend to
about
700 or 800 meters before i think
that i would beat him
fair enough okay tell us about your 15-3
fdmc the new plymouth boys high at the
galley in 1999 and the celebration
yeah it was it was pretty special it was
uh my first
you know go back so we had never beaten
you plymouth boys high
jimmy just to give you a bit of
background and um
yeah now well we were at school only 40
years old by that stage but never
beaten this you were at nine i was uh at
nine yep for that game
i had a bit of a busted shoulder but i
strapped it up
and uh and yeah well it wasn't i've
actually still got a video of that game
i watched it a few years ago it wasn't
the most entertaining but
uh we we were we were a very good
fifteen we had been uh
together for like a bunch of us like
right through
playing together and you know i
i wasn't one of the uh it wasn't one of
the best players but there were a couple
others that were
very good that was sort of playing
northern regions as it was back then so
that taranaki and then yeah and
um getting close to new zealand sort of
age group teams and
boys i to be fair to them we're a bit of
a younger team with the jimmy gopath
playing for them
um still a good team oh wow but yeah
we've been still going yeah we've been
motivated for
like since we started high school to be
the ones to beat boys high so
that was uh it was a massive massive
achievement
and uh yeah three three tries to zero
all
unconverted we had a number eight
kicking our goals who i'm still friends
with
brendan hart so i'm gonna love including
him on this podcast he was zero he also
attempted two penalties that he missed
so the fifth two tries to our captain
john weddington who's an amazing amazing
player
and uh i don't know who scored the other
one but yeah remember it
very very well but it wasn't much of a i
mean it was a wednesday game so
i think we just had a few drinks we were
all obviously
underage so it wasn't too much of a uh
celebration i think we would have waited
for a house party or something like that
on the
following the following weekend
you would have been deadly at a house
party
right i wasn't up to much at that age to
be honest
i hadn't heard the i hadn't learnt the
uh layla or
the value of uh the value of 330
yoyos so
that's good stuff okay this is a good
question if you could partner with
another international 12 in the midfield
who would you go
oh sean de villiers just because he's a
top top obviously amazing player but um
yeah really good guy i get on really
well with even now and
um and but and when we played
south africa in new zealand obviously
you know huge rivalry but
he was one guy even during a game him
and i we
obviously had a similar mentality and in
terms of being competitive but
uh still didn't take it too seriously so
we'd
we'd uh have good fun you know even
playing against each other and
um and yeah and i just loved his style
of play and
um what he did so yeah he'd be my choice
what a lad okay
what did you do when you had a
sabbatical instead of going on the end
of your tour
yeah that was when when i uh i traveled
um
so my wife and i hit it off and just
travelled for three months so that's
so i'd done that after the world cup and
um
so it was that 2011. but as it was then
because after world cups you get her
quite a good offseason
and i had asked at that time just to
miss the first
two weeks of pre-season with the
hurricanes just because i just really
wanted to travel it was something i was
desperate to do since i was you know at
university
and i like rugby was sort of taking that
option away it was sort of
you know i was loving obviously being a
rugby player but i
loved traveling and i wanted to do it
you know while i was still young and
um we had had a great you know three
months
after that world cup and i felt it was
something that
energized me for that 2012 season so
when i resigned with new zealand rugby i
just asked that
if i could do that again and i'd miss an
indian tour and the payments and stuff
that go with that but
i just felt it was key to sort of
prolong my career and and then build
into the next world cup so they were
happy to allow it so yeah my wife and i
we just planned another trip and went
sort of a few different places
a few similar places saw friends in
europe and
and that was uh that was it back to the
charity on the on the way home and
went to a wedding with friends of ours
on the way so it was just uh
it was a good yeah it was awesome it was
a great break
was that when you went trekking with um
the silverback gorillas or
when was it yeah yeah that was on the
second trip we uh well both times
like when we went through africa we'd
visit the charity and then
we went to the serengeti did the whole
uh that experience with the
the lions and the zebras and all that
and then yeah
what the other truck we went into uganda
and tripped into the rainforest and uh
it's been a spent a few hours with the
silverback gorillas so
you may i i love all that stuff and um
you know my wife does too so it was
something we were fortunate enough to
get
you know to build that in so we've got
to experience those sorts of things that
you wouldn't otherwise do in a
two or three week offseason that you
normally have
oh good stuff okay as an intellect do
you have any ambitions to go back to
varsity and study again
i i thought about that uh you know
when i talked before that i was going to
finish with the all blacks
i um i actually yeah it was quite close
to
looking to go back to cambridge um and
doing a masters there
and you know because that would give us
a you know chance to live overseas
um but yeah it just didn't
motivate me hugely i didn't really know
what i would study and
um and yeah that i mean that whole
cambridge
experience would be pretty cool but i
just didn't know
for a family it wouldn't wouldn't be
quite the same as living in
the south of france so uh that that's
why that
never sort of eventuated now probably a
little bit past it so uh
but yeah well it was close for a while
okay what do you put down to being at
the top of your game for so long
um i i just
you know i think most i think it's not
just in rugby but
your personality and more than anything
just uh
your attention to detail and your
competitiveness i i know
that's um probably probably the things
that keep you motivated
like you just never i was never relaxed
as a
as all blast i talked to friends about
this because they talk about how
it must have been scraping and all black
for so long and but
i i can honestly say it was never
a time when i ever felt
comfortable um in my position like
you're always
pushing yourself to be better and
feeling like you had to be better or
else there was going to be someone that
took your spot
or else you know you you weren't going
to perform the way you wanted to perform
for the team and
and that's great right like that that's
why the team does so well and
um that's the sort of culture you you
need uh
but you know i think that's what sort of
drives guys to stay
to stay on top of the game you just
never complacent you never
relax which isn't it's actually when you
retire it's quite nice to be relaxed
um but uh certainly
it's certainly what what you need to
have you know to stay at that level
oh good answer okay what is your best
memory as the obu billy goat
oh a lot a lot
to be fair it would be the social side
which um
i don't know if i should say but i love
being a student then
meeting meeting that club i didn't know
what club so i was down to wellington
obviously wanted to play rugby didn't
really know what club
but the logical thing was to play for
the varsity and
um yeah me great bunch of guys
obviously you know guys i mentioned
before were great rugby players some
super players
and um like spicy and pukku but just
the attitude towards rugby and that and
that team was just so good
in terms of uh you know students we play
some we played great rugby we
we enjoyed ourselves off the field but
and we you know we
were friends and i caught up with spicy
just two days ago
he's still a good mate and uh it was
just
good good fun and that's what you know
maybe
i don't know at the moment there's a lot
of talk about the community game and
people not playing
rugby as long as they should or and not
motivated to play for their clubs but
for me man i got i didn't need to play
for the hurricanes or the
then i would have i was going to turn up
every week just to play club rugby just
because it was fun it was
uh it was all about winning but we was a
social group that
you know we were my best bunch of mates
you know outside of like had to eat my
uni crew but this is with my um the
rugby club and
it was uh it was what provided a lot of
fun and um
yes i i just i just think for me that
there was never question of that i would
stop playing rugby because i had such a
good
team that i was playing with
how good okay is it true your mum made
you cut your hair before your all black
debut
no i don't think there was much truth to
that i think uh
that that would have been my own
decision i don't know i don't know i
had some outrageous he do so i think
anyone that would have seen my
range of haircuts would know my mum
didn't have uh much saying
the hero i was rolling around with
okay next question who's the best center
in the world at the moment
oh oh um
who do i say here i get asked about i'm
a jet
i'm a jack goody fan in new zealand i
think he's a
brilliant player and i think he should
start 13 but i won't get any uh more
controversial than that
outside of that around the traps
slade's pretty handy in england um
jonathan davies when he's fit and
playing for
wales he even you know i was playing him
he's
he he would be he would be the best at
the moment just
you know as experienced as he is um and
as good as he is he's
he's an outstanding player and he's had
a lot of injuries in the you know recent
years but he is
he's class good
stuff okay this one this one might be
controversial for some listeners but
who was fitter you or richie mccor
running fitness running running fitness
well i said again the value of weight
mccool was carrying another you know 10
or so kilos on me so
he um he could run all day but on a
fitness test i would i would i would
beat him
as as would a couple other backs as well
he he would always win
in the forward so he was the fittest
forward but uh if you're judging fitness
just by those sort of numbers then
i've got him what about a coaster coast
or something yeah well
at the moment he'd be uh he'd be in his
own element
well i'm trying to hold down a bit more
of a job and have to have the time to do
those sorts of things but
he's one guy who wasn't ever on social
media who jumped [ __ ] wasn't he he was
and we had a lot of fun talking about
this because
this was this in his last year of
playing and he had a lot of advice
around the uh
the opportunities that would present
themselves if he went on to social media
and
because he obviously uh had enjoyed it
you know being a player you get plenty
of exposure but they sort of said to him
you need to
get on the social media gimmick and
um so he jumped [ __ ] and he always said
he wouldn't
so yeah i was the only one that was the
only one by the end that was
oh yeah i was holding strong
oh that's good okay how many fluoro
track suits do you own
i is this your question
i own one this is a stephie
i own one bright yellow fluro because
it's not even mine it was hard i don't
know where
it was a family tracksuit i don't even
know where it is but it's
it's had a lot of use
a lot of youth very popular
in the season um what do we call that in
the season
cup of tea it's uh had a lot of youth
okay this question came up a lot but i
thought the answer would have already
been out there how did you get the
nickname
snakey it was it's a very it's not much
of a story i need to make something up
better but it was just
it was a cricket coach actually back to
talking about my cricket
and uh i i was i was
i enjoyed fielding i kept myself active
obviously cricket can be quite a
challenging game when you're a long time
in the field so i provided
plenty of voice and i was just i'd
chased down anything
and one coach thought i looked like a
snake the way i moved around the field
and it was actually laughed at you know
like as a stupid nickname but
often that's why how these got things
stuck and
i read something i was reading something
yesterday and it said that it was
because you
used to slither through tackles and
things like this
well that's why some people like they
don't know the reason so they just make
up their own
yeah do people still call you snakey or
is that sort of gone with the rugby no
it's everywhere it just creeps in is
that because one person
so start work with the international
players and
you you'll start talking to a couple of
ex-players and they'll they would have
known me by
like you know brian habaner's on a
couple of committees with me and he
starts calling me snake and then he was
like what
and then so it just follows me i do try
to shake it
my wife is dead keen on me to shake it
but
i think it's i think it's swiftly to
life
and at least it's a good nickname okay
last question one piece of advice you
would give
a young conrad smith oh no
i think we've talked about it before you
just
you got to be motivated by enjoyment you
know i i think doesn't
whether it's rugby or whatever your
sport or whatever you do you know you
just got to uh
if you're trying to do it to make teams
or
build your social media account or build
your bank balance then
you won't get through the you know the
injuries and the tough times but if you
just love
love what you do if you love playing
rugby i you know that for me was
always a thing then you can sort of ride
out those times and then uh
and it gets you out of bed more than any
of those other things will
so that's that's always uh my advice
just
enjoy what you do enjoy enjoy the
challenges as much as
the accolades and and you can have a
have a good time
oh i knew you had come up with some
great advice some of the best we've had
so far
what a career what a journey what a lad
conrad smith
the greatest teammate i've had um thanks
for coming on and giving up your time
obviously like i said you're one of my
favorite players growing up one of my
favorite players to play with and
i honestly don't think i would have had
the hurricane career that i did if you
weren't
there um i owe a lot to you you were a
massive influence on me during my time
at the hurricane so i just want to thank
you for that and thanks for coming on
the waterlab
show too easy jimmy you doing you're
doing a good job you're making
showing the fun out of rugby i i like it
it should be uh
more shows like you we don't need a we
don't need to break down tactics too
much when you're playing rugby it's a
bit of fun eh
i like it yeah 100 hey appreciate it
thanks man
all right no problem